As you may know, naturally created diamonds
are formed from carbon subjected to extreme
pressure (725,000 pounds per square inch or
so) and heat (1,650 to 2,370 °F) some 90-120
miles down.
The world’s natural diamond supply (that
has come to the surface) was formed in this
way some 1-3 billion years ago.
However, scientists only realized that diamonds
are the crystallized form of carbon in 1772
when Antoine Lavoisier made the discovery.
Despite work by numerous scientists in the
intervening years, the first synthetic diamonds
weren’t created until 1954 by one Howard
Tracy Hall.
Born in 1919 in Ogden, Utah, Hall grew up
in nearby Marriott.
His family were members of the Mormon Church
and lived on a farm far enough from town that
heading there for supplies meant the whole
family went along for the ride.
Hall and his brothers waited at the Ogden
City Library for their parents to finish their
business.
There Hall learned about Thomas Edison and
quickly became fascinated by the inventor.
As a child, he reportedly vowed to one day
work for Edison’s company, General Electric
(GE).
Hall earned an associate’s degree in 1939
and a bachelor’s degree in 1942.
World War II interrupted his course of education.
After enlisting in the U.S. Navy in 1944,
Hall trained in radar and electronics at Harvard
University.
He served as an ensign until 1946 before stepping
back into university courses and completing
his PhD in Chemistry in 1948.
Then he achieved his childhood dream: he moved
across the country to work at GE’s laboratory
located in Schenectady, New York.
GE hired Hall to fill the role of chemist
in the team for their recently launched “Project
Superpressure,” a project designed to create
the first synthetic diamonds.
GE spent $125,000 in 1951 (approximately $1.17
million today) on a twenty-five foot tall
press capable of generating 1.6 million pounds
per square inch of pressure.
The planned press also required GE to build
a three story building specifically to house
it.
Two years after construction on the press
began, it was finally finished and the physicists
involved in the team set about running failed
experiment after failed experiment with it.
Hall thought GE and the team that designed
the machine were approaching the problem wrong
and believed there was a better, simpler way.
In fact, he thought with a few modifications
and a custom designed apparatus, he could
use a leaky, 35 year old Watson-Stillman press
to do the job.
But when he approached his bosses at GE for
the $1,000 he thought he needed to complete
the modifications, they turned him down.
After all, a team of extremely well educated
physicists thought it could only be done with
their shiny new, very expensive, machine.
An old Watson-Stillman press could never be
sufficient for the job, no matter how much
he modified it.
Aside from denying him the money to make the
modifications, GE also gave priority in the
machining shop to the physicists on the Project
Superpressure team, making it so Hall could
not continue working on his idea that way
either.
However, Hall refused to let his bosses’
disinterest and skepticism in the project
stop him.
He convinced a friendly machinist to help
him after hours in building his newly developed
“belt” apparatus.
However, since the steel available in the
machinist’s shop was not strong enough to
handle the extreme pressure Hall needed his
“belt” apparatus to handle, he again approached
the GE execs.
He asked them to purchase a substance called
carboloy, consisting of 6% cobalt and 94%
tungsten carbide.
Thanks to the intervention of a sympathetic
supervisor, Herman Liebhafksy, who had been
integral to Hall getting the job in the first
place when he insisted they needed to add
a chemist to the Project Superpressure team,
GE purchased the expensive carboloy for Hall.
With his machine finally built, Hall set about
experimenting with it.
It took him several attempts at creating synthetic
diamonds before he discovered the correct
method.
But on December 16, 1954, Hall worked alone
at the GE laboratory after the rest of the
staff had gone home for the Christmas holiday.
He later described opening the pressure chamber
after one of his experiments and discovering
the diamonds: “My hands began to tremble;
my heart beat rapidly; my knees weakened and
no longer gave support.
My eyes had caught the flashing light from
dozens of tiny… crystals.”
Hall performed the experiment several more
times just to be sure it wasn’t a fluke,
each time with the same result.
He then asked his colleague, Hugh H. Woodbury,
to conduct the test himself.
Woodbury was a fellow GE chemist, and he successfully
used Hall’s relatively cheaply built “belt”
press apparatus on New Year’s Eve 1954 to
create synthetic diamonds just as Hall had.
When Hall informed his bosses at GE about
the success he achieved with his makeshift
device, they were skeptical.
After all, this was a device that could be
built at home in someone’s garage, with
a little know-how.
Their skepticism disappeared when they witnessed
the experiment themselves.
Hall left the building before the test specifically
so that they could not claim he doctored the
results somehow.
After being thoroughly convinced the method
was consistently repeatable, GE announced
on February 14, 1955 that the company had
created the world’s first synthetic diamonds.
However, they initially claimed it was more
of a team effort by physicists and other researchers
as part of Project Superpressure, rather than
it being mostly just Hall working on the project
on the side and simply modifying an old press
to suit his purposes.
They also stated the diamonds were created
on their extremely expensive press.
You see, GE invested a lot of money into the
press and the team they had put together to
design and use it, and weren’t keen on admitting
to the world that it had all been a waste
and that the diamonds in question were instead
created on Hall’s leaky old, readily available
to the public in its non-modified form, apparatus.
That latter point was particularly of concern
for them, as they didn’t want people to
know that this thing could be built by just
about anyone who knew the design, without
too much expense.
(Later, some would do just this once the details
of the design came out.)
Internally, GE knew the real story and were
happy to give credit where it was due.
If they couldn’t reward him with name recognition
publicly, at least they could give Hall a
bonus.
As such, for being the first in close to a
couple hundred years of scientists and engineers
to manage to create something that previously
took billions of years to form, GE officially
awarded Hall with a $25 (about $200 today)
U.S. Savings bond for his efforts…
(Note: most sources claim it was $10, without
providing reference; the H. Tracy Hall Foundation
states it was a $25 bond, of which Hall stated,
“Big deal.”)
Whatever the case, this slap in the face of
a bonus was the last straw.
Had he been given proper credit, rather than
it going to a team, with his role being highly
marginalized, it is generally thought that
Hall would have been inline for a Nobel Prize,
among other accolades.
As it was, disheartened with the way GE treated
him, he wasted no time looking for other work.
Being involved with the team that had managed
to make synthetic diamonds was certainly a
valuable thing, in and of itself, even if
most didn’t know the full truth at this
time.
So Hall had no shortage of job offers.
Rather than go work for another company, though,
he instead took an offer from Brigham Young
University in Utah to become a professor of
chemistry and director of research.
While his original intent was to continue
his research on the belt apparatus, the United
States government decided the invention was
too important to allow that.
They put a secrecy order on the apparatus
and effectively prohibited him from working
on it or talking about how it was made.
Violation of this would mean a substantial
monetary fine and imprisonment.
tetrahedral-pressHall got around this by,
within a year, simply inventing a completely
different machine, the tetrahedral press (full
details on the design can be found here in
the patent), which accomplished the same thing
as his original, but technically didn’t
violate the gag-order, nor would it infringe
on GE’s eventual patent on his original
machine once the gag-order was lifted and
he was able to file said patent and get proper
credit for its invention.
(US Patent No 2,941,248)
However, getting off on a technicality didn’t
sit well with some in the government and he
was initially threatened with 2 years imprisonment
and a $10,000 fine (about $88,000 today) for
inventing this machine.
Further, his new machine was likewise slapped
with a gag-order.
Fortunately for Dr. Hall, the government did
not follow through with arresting him and
ultimately lifted the secrecy order on his
machines, allowing him to continue improving
his designs and, finally, publish and profit
from his groundbreaking work.
Thanks to this, Hall went on to publish nearly
150 peer-reviewed papers and to win research
grants totaling over $1 million.
He even co-founded a very successful synthetic
diamond company of his own called MegaDiamond,
which is still around today.
Hall ultimately retired into the life of a
tree farmer, passing away in July of 2008
at the age of 88.
In his later years, when asked about his most
important accomplishment in his life, Hall
simply stated, “Home and family.
That’s the most important.”